hey eric could you play a cambridge
springs oh
i could try cambridge springs requires
white to play
like kind of mainline queen's gambit
hey gumpy plays queen's gambit
okay
so this is casual that's good so the
goal is to
play a cambridge springs
let's see if my opponent allows it
if for some reason we don't go into it
i'll still play like a cambridge springs
repertoire
where
there are certain lines if you play
cambridge springs you can try and be
more aggressive than normal
yeah so i'm allowing
bishop g5
now the move order i like to start with
is
is knight d7
uh setting up the elephant trap
if takes takes takes
i can temporarily sack the queen and
then win it right back
and then after all said and done black
is up a piece in that line
i do have a video on youtube
it's called something like five queens
gamut traps everyone should know
i cover this trap i actually share some
cambridge springs lines in that video as
well
but uh okay this is nice to see
queen a5 is officially cambridge springs
i'm not sure the history of this is
opening
maybe somehow related to cambridge
maybe during springtime
so the general moves black likes to play
are uh our bishop b4 and knight e4
i'm thinking i can start with knight e4
if i play bishop b4 i give
white the chance to take
when i start with knight e4
i'm already putting pressure against
knight and against the bishop
so we have this nice
triangle
what do you call a triangle where all
the sides are different lengths scalene
scalene isosceles
right equilateral
so many different types of triangles
okay so now bishop to b4
now there's three attackers against a
knight
and this is a very common situation in
cambridge springs where
like the only way for white to defend
the knight the third time is to play
this move
which loses a2 pawn
because knight's pinned
now it's still going to be a fight
but we'll see what white does
thank you nasage hey how's it going
hey you it's going well how are you
oh yeah i forgot about the bermuda
triangle
that's like a more dangerous type of
triangle
but also maybe touristy
bermuda triangle is also i'd imagine
scalene
or maybe it's like
[Music]
a wonder if it's like a
[Music]
no
doesn't say an octagon but
as long as there's three points
okay so the issue for white with playing
a3
is that the bay pawn is pinned to the
rook
so white's not actually threatening to
take
meanwhile i can take here
and
i want a piece
and now i win more material
so i think this is a nice illustration
of how to
just punish some like really common
mistakes for white in this opening
because white played a lot of like
queen's gambit like natural types of
moves
but uh yeah if the opponent doesn't know
how to deal with the pressure
things can crumble quickly
after the game i'll share
i'll share the most common trap
that like so many players walk into
but let's finish this off first
i think the strategy here is just to
simplify
the lights now pinned by my my queen
bishop battery
and the king's tie down to defending the
knight
so
yeah there's no reason to take the
pinned piece
i don't mind trading
bring the knight in
this pawn is actually hanging
oh this one's also hanging
ah
okay so there's four different things i
can take
i wanted to try and win material but if
takes the bishop takes back
and
yeah i'd like to keep this bishop
oh
[Music]
okay i should have seen this move coming
thankfully i have this move so
everything should still be
okay
and white could take take rook t1
oh but then i take the bishop
yeah this is where i i just start trying
to simplify
trade down a bit
now the bishops are skewered by the
queen and f3 is impossible because f1 is
pinned
so we might see rookie one
after rookie one i'll take the bishop
and then if queen takes i trade queens
if rook takes
then
queen a1
not quite mate
there's this or this
actually queen a1 didn't really
accomplish so much
uh i want to play this move
normally this should probably not be
played but
i'm trying to win quickly
i'm setting up this bishop f5
pin skewer thing
the drawback of e5 is i'm subjecting my
king to danger i'm also cutting off the
diagonal for my queen
but it's all with good intention
oh no white's queen
queen c3 was a double attack though
but uh sometimes queens are not good at
double attacking other queens
to be fair white was a long time
but hopefully some lessons to take away
from that game
um
yeah as white i think queen c2 is
playable
the safe move is bishop takes f6 just to
like avoid any any troubles i think a
top level play like cd5 or knight d2 are
the
the two more common choices among ground
masters
but i'll go ahead and show like the most
common trap
here and it happens after
like one of the most natural moves for
white is bishop to d3
just like very common queen's gambit
developing move
the reason why this is
not good for white is because after it
takes
takes 94
the knight and the queen are attacking
two different things
uh coordination is really nice and again
we see this
scalene triangle but really just a
double attack
and it's funny that like most people
as white play queen c2
not realizing that the bishop is
attacked twice
because it can be easy to miss
backward knight moves but also
long distance queen moves
have i had this position
never had this position as white but
i've had it three times as black
i've had this position five times
yeah i used to play cambridge rings more
often but my the move i encounter most
of this position is bishop d3
anyway so i hope that was a useful
lesson
this is probably more youtube content
i sleeping when you play chess big
sometimes i chess also i try master
horse piece but i have not so good as
him move confusingly yeah how long
before there are big number in name like
you
thank you for making
uh you welcome